and the reason I want to go back to what
I was saying to gem earlier on the
reason I'm trying to talk about
protection is because you don't
understand that sometimes us men will do
protection in a different way you didn't
see what I was doing in litter's
protection
just hold on a second but she did it she
was talking about a gun but I was trying
to say the type of character that you
meet a man he does not know you he's
witnessed you kissing another man yeah
saying goodbye to him so I'm not trying
to move to you he's going to set in a
lift with you and count I should be
grateful that you're not nice oh no no
he's making an example get the point get
the point but you should put the point
no no but as women we need to get the
point that men are trying to give us